ja ich trau dem Frieden in der Tat nicht
denn wenn Ampel Partner wenn
Koalitionspartner insgesamt drei Tage
zusammen sitzen müssen um Dinge zu
beschließen die zum Teil schon im
Koalitionsvertrag eigentlich standen ein
bisschen aufgeschoben waren aber sich
eigentlich über 30 Stunden nicht so
richtig einigen können dann sagt das
sehr sehr viel über ein Bündnis aus und
es hat in dem Fall ja auch viel
ausgesagt man hat sich noch einmal
zusammengerauft nach einer 30-stündigen
Marathon Sitzung rote grüne und gelbe
ich glaube aber das ist das Fundament
der Ampel mittlerweile so bröselig ist
wie Ostsee Sand und ähm die Stimmung im
Bündnis so schlecht wie nie zuvor
Friedrich Merz sollte sich darauf
vorbereiten zumindest in der Lage zu
sein wenn es zu einem Tag X kommt in
diesem Land Bundeskanzler zu werden
was glaubst du wie tief du hast das ganz
nah verfolgt in diesen letzten
vergangenen Stunden wie tief ist der
Graben in der Koalition wirklich was
ging da ab hinter den Kulissen der
Graben ist nach allem was wir hören was
ich gehört habe extrem tief niemand
traut eigentlich dem anderen mehr so
richtig über den Weg das wird alles weg
moderiert von einem Bundeskanzler der
das Wort sehr sehr mittlerweile so
strapaziert dass er zum Teil dreimal das
Wort sehr sagt wie gut die Ergebnisse
sind wie gut die Stimmung in der Ampel
ist aber nach allem was man ja auch
zwischen den Zeilen hört und was wir so
mitbekommen an Gesprächen die geführt
werden gibt es vor allem zwischen SPD
und also oder anders zwischen FDP und
Grünen sehr sehr viel
Kommunikationsprobleme Streit ganz klar
und ähm es gibt auch zwischen SPD und
FDP natürlich Raibach rein es gibt
zwischen SPD und Grünen auch einfach
rein aber am Ende stehen sich grüne und
SPD immer noch ein bisschen näher in
vielen Dingen als der mit der FDP und in
diesem diesen 30 Stunden hat halt
irgendwie jeder auch mit jedem und auch
gegen jeden gekämpft die Grünen fühlen
sich einmal mehr als Verlierer die FDP
als Sieger und ein Kernproblem ist muss
man auch sagen in dieser Koalition ist
das Olaf Scholz der Bundeskanzler mit
Christian Lindner sprechen kann der ist
Finanzministerin FDP-Chef und die FDP so
strukturiert dass das was Lindner sagt
in der Regel dann auch als Wort
Machtwort verstanden wird bei den Grünen
ist das völlig anders wenn Olaf Scholz
mit Robert habe kommuniziert dann
kommuniziert er wirklich nur mit Robert
habe aber er kommuniziert nicht mit der
Parteispitze und schon gar nicht mit der
Fraktionsspitze und das führt dazu auch
in diesen 30 Stunden wieder das es immer
wieder Gesprächsrunden Gesprächsbedarf
bei den Grünen gibt weil man sich nicht
einig ist weil Robert habe ich nicht die
Prokura hat für die Partei zu sprechen
und das macht natürlich so ein Bündnis
extrem schwierig und ich weiß nicht wie
lange die Minister posten und das Geld
und der Dienstwagen dieses Bündnis dann
am Ende noch zusammenschweißt ganz klar
ist auf jeden Fall die Grünen die
mussten ordentlich Federn lassen ne kann
man sagen wir schon einmal gemeinsam
ich will ganz ehrlich sein reicht das
was du beim Klimaschutz drinsteht nein
vor allem beim Verkehr bleibt eine große
Lücke wenn es um die Revolution von CO2
geht gleichzeitig sind da Fortschritte
drin ja und deshalb sind wir am Ende
diesen Weg gegangen zu sagen statt dass
es einen Rückschritt kriegt beim
Klimaschutz kämpfen wir für mehr
Klimaschutz innerhalb dieser Koalition
oft tun wir es ehrlich gesagt auch
ziemlich alleine und wir werden auch
weiter kämpfen oft sind wieder ziemlich
alleine Herr Heilmann sagt Ricarda
langer und ihr Parteikollege Jens Spahn
der hat im übrigen nach dem
Verhandlungen eine Jamaika Fahne
getwittert ist das eine einzelung oder
glauben Sie der Stößer bei ihnen in der
Partei auf ordentlich Unterstützung
naja also der Streit zwischen FDP und
Grünen wird ja nicht aufgelöst wenn die
jetzt die SPD rauswerfen die CDU nehmen
dann bleibt diese positionsunterschiede
auch und die Ricarda lang hat Recht
die FDP hat sich durchgesetzt wird immer
Verkehr sie verletzen nach wie vor das
Klimaschutzgesetz das ist
Verfassungsgericht für
eine verfassungspflicht eingestuft hat
das ist schon ziemlich keine Löser
Vorgang und am Ende des Tages weichen
sich jetzt das Klimaschutzgesetz auf das
dem die Grünen im Bundestag durch
zustimmen werden also wir werden nämlich
zustimmen kann ich sagen und dass wir
jetzt die Grünen sozusagen beim
Klimaschutz überholen das hätte ich mir
auch nicht träumen lassen aber so geht
es ja nicht wir können doch nicht sagen
die Erde haben uns ist egal wir machen
das nicht die FDP ist einfach nur
Debatte und das was Frau langsack ist ja
oberscheinheilig Frau lang ist
Vorsitzender einer Partei die wirklich
ein ernstes Jahr gesagt dass sie müsste
jetzt alle Kernkraftwerke die noch am
Netz sind abscheiden und gleichzeitig
Kohlekraftwerke hochzufahren also was
verschleudert und verschmutzt die die
Atmosphäre und die Luft jetzt noch
stärker als Kohlekraftwerke das frag ich
auch sie also man kann ja nicht sich
beschweren darüber dass der
Verkehrssektor nicht seine CO2 Ziele
erfüllt und gleichzeitig aber sagen wir
müssen jetzt alles hochfahren was CO2
rausschmeißt nur damit wir die Kernkraft
die nahezu CO2 neutral ist runterfahren
also deswegen da tragen Sie also gar
nicht häufig genug wahrscheinlich tragen
also natürlich dieses absolut idiotisch
jetzt mehr Kohlekraftwerke laufen zu
lassen statt die vorhandenen
Atomkraftwerke länger laufen zu lassen
das ist Unsinn so ähm aber da darum ging
es ja jetzt in diesem Gipfel oder in
diesem koalitionsverhandlung nicht
sondern da ging sondern im Bereich
Verkehr und im Bereich der Verkehr ist
der einzige Bereich der nicht sinkt
trotz der Kohle jetzt frage ich aber
sehr gesinken die CO2-Emissionen bei
Energie bei weil wir da im Weiterkommen
bei Verkehr eben nicht und
das wird jetzt auch noch sozusagen
abgesiegnet mit diesem Beschluss
und dann hat heute herr Scholz gesagt
naja wir werden mehr Klimaschutz im
Gesetz haben obwohl wir die sektorziele
bei Verkehr aufweichen wie das aufgehen
soll ist mir schleierhaft und dann
wollte ich insofern stimme ich ihn dazu
dann feiern die Grünen als Erfolg dass
wir jetzt wieder 15 Milliarden Euro die
schon zu cdu-zeiten für die
Infrastruktur der Bahn ausgeben die
Ampel hatte ist auf 8,9 gesenkt also um
6 Milliarden pro Jahr und die werden es
wieder aufgefüllt ist doch gar kein
Fortschritte die haben einfach nur die
Kürzung zurückgenommen also da ist sehr
wenig wirklich Fortschritt zu sehen
bedeutet
das in schwarz gelb-grün könnte das
funktionieren ich komme noch mal zurück
auf Jens Spahn ich habe da noch nicht
eine eindeutige Antwort von Ihnen
bekommen und das denke ich einzeln
Wunsch ist also ich würde mir natürlich
auch wünschen dass die CDU wieder
regiert sich natürlich auch super
verdeutlichen CDU-Politiker die
die Konflikte zwischen FTP und Grüne die
ja auch mit uns genauso in derselben
Regierung setzen werden natürlich nicht
aufgehoben nur weil wir einen besseren
Moderator hätten also Angela Merkel hat
schwierige Phasen anders moderiert als
das Olaf Scholz tut das hat er immer
keine drin
die Ampel auseinanderbricht was ich noch
nicht so schnell glaube aber wenn sie
auseinanderbricht wird neu waren in
Deutschland geben muss man mal klar
sagen der wird glaube ich keine andere
Kollektion auf wen würden Sie sich wen
würden Sie sich wünschen dass das eine
schwarz grüne Regierung in Deutschland
schneller voran käme wir würden
natürlich genauso wie wie darauf achten
dass jetzt etwa bei den
heizungsbeschlüssen die soziale Balance
gewahrt wird dass wir dann die Aufgabe
der CDU ähm aber ich glaube wir müssen
etwas für die gegen die Erderwärmung tun
denn das nicht zu tun das teuerste für
die Bürger was wir machen kann warum
haben wir jetzt Inflation weil wir
Staatsschulden haben aber ich verstehe
und wenn wir wenn wir das weiß ich gar
nicht aber die die und wenn wir jetzt
das alles vertagen dann wird es
hinterher nur teurer aber wenn es mir
den Grünen so schwierig ist wieso will
dann die CD unbedingt jetzt verstehe ich
gar nicht also Klimaschutz das habe ich
ja in ein Parteiprogramm gesehen da
gibt's unterschiedliche Schattierungen
und ähm es gibt unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen wie man die Dinge umsetzt
aber eindeutig erkennen wir doch beim
Thema Klimaschutz tun sich was die
Umsetzung angeht wenn man es mit anderen
Partei macht die Grünen am schwersten
wenn man an den Markt in gewisser Weise
auch glaubt tun sich die Gründe auch am
schwersten die hätten sie am liebsten
stringent durchregiert von oben Verbote
alles per Strom nicht technologieoffen
so und das ist die Marschrichtung der
grüne Parteien wie die CDU oder die FDP
aber auch die SPD die das nicht ganz so
strikt sehen deswegen sind das ja keine
schlechteren klimaschütze also noch mal
die Frage warum ausgerechnet mit der
Partei die ist am kompliziertesten macht
weil ich glaube dass die SPD die ja am
längsten in Deutschland den letzten 30
Jahren regiert hat man denkt ja was war
die CDU stimmt aber nicht die SPD hat
länger regiert
[Musik]
aber die
die es gibt nur eine einzige
Legislaturperiode nämlich die eine mit
der FDP die die Union gemacht hat sonst
war die SPD immer in der Regierung
deswegen glaube ich dass man da
weiterkommt aber ich bin ja ihre Meinung
ich bin ja in der CDU nicht bei den
Grünen wir müssen also wir dürfen auf
keinen Fall beim Klimaschutz einfach
nichts tun aber wir sollten es unbedingt
marktwirtschaftlich tun und nicht statt
die registisch und das ist die große
Schattenseite
befragen das Stichwort neue Wahlen da
wird ein bisschen jetzt rum spekuliert
für wie wahrscheinlich halten sie das
oder anders gefragt wie wahrscheinlich
halten Sie dass die Koalition stabil
bleibt bis zum Ende der
Legislaturperiode also ich glaube jetzt
nicht dass es so schnell auseinander
geht weil natürlich auch alle sich jetzt
an ihre Posten Klammern das ist ja das
normale Spiel ich habe dir jetzt vor der
Sendung noch mal diese 16 Seiten
durchgelesen und war wirklich
erschrocken dass man nach so einer
langen stundenlanger Sitzung denkt man
ja so jetzt kommt irgendwie was ganz
tolles was so ein Aufbruch für
Deutschland signalisiert so eine tolle
leuchtturmgeschichte eine tolle Idee und
dann kämpft man sich wirklich durch
diese 16 Seiten Geschwurbel durch einer
sagte vorhin das sein 16 Seiten Blabla
und das finde ich eigentlich eine
verheerende Signal was natürlich auch
wieder die Leute dazu führt dass sie
sagen was machen die denn da eigentlich
in Berlin diese Kluft geht dann
natürlich viel weiter auseinander und
wenn man sich diese 16 Seiten durchguckt
und dann hat man natürlich das Gefühl
das ist Saft und kraftlos was diese
Regierung macht trotzdem glaube ich
nicht dass sie so schnell auseinander
geht ich fand interessant was er einmal
gesagt hat dass er sich als
CDU-Politiker eigentlich den Grünen viel
mehr fühlt als der FDP das war ja auch
mal anders ne
die das war mal anders das ist gebrochen
2017 als Lindner da kannst ja bis heute
inhaltlich nicht begründen gesagt hat
lieber nicht regieren als schlecht
regieren jetzt regierter schlecht also
was da also das war einfach unlogisch
und das hat in der Union auch in der CSU
übrigens zu großen nachdenkenprozessen
geführt und muss klar zu sagen wir
unterscheiden uns von den Grünen in
vielen Leitung
wir sollten klarere Ziele formulieren
die auch verlässlicher für die Menschen
und die Wirtschaft kommunizieren aber
den Lösungsweg in die Leute selber
finden lassen und mich irgendwie bis ins
Detail vorgeben dass ich obwohl ich
jetzt eine Biogasanlage schon habe aber
wenn mein Haus umgebaut wird und das
rechtlichen Neubau wird dann muss ich
die abkleben aus der Bibel
näher da kommen wir nämlich gleich auch
noch richtig dazu ich möchte einmal den
Blick auch von außen quasi dazu holen
herr Meyer wenn Sie uns so reden hören
wirklich ich beneidet Deutschland um
diese farbige lebhafte Politik
und ich beneide Deutschland darum dass
es möglich ist dass die grünen Teil der
Regierung sein können das ist bei uns
absolut unvorstellbar trotzdem wird
gerade bei uns immer wieder von der
grünen Diktatur gesprochen wir haben ja
den Bundesrat die meisten wissen dass
dem sieben Menschen angehören aber
niemand kann die aufzählen weil es auch
wirklich nicht eine besondere Rolle
spielt die tun aber jedes mal so als
ging es jetzt darum Leben und Tod bei
den Wahlen sehr interessant und wenn ich
ihn so zuhöre dann tue ich das
mit Neid muss ich offen sagen ich
wundere mich ein bisschen über Sie Herr
Heilmann weil wenn man sich
wählerprofile anschaut ziemlich klar ist
wo das Milieu für CDU wieder liegt da
gibt es die meisten Überschneidungen mit
der FDP da braucht man gar nicht
drumherum zu reden also die Faszination
vieler CDU-Politiker auch von ihnen zu
den Grünen aus welcher aus welchem Grund
die auch kommt die fällt mir immer
wieder schwer zu glauben also wenn man
an die soziale Marktwirtschaft glaubt
wie ist die CDU ja tut zumindest sagt
sie ist immer die FDP tut das auch die
Grünen tun es nicht die sagen es war sie
tun es aber nicht keine
marktwirtschaftliche Partei ist eine
dirigistische Partei da sind Sie ja
schon in den Grundfesten völlig
unterschiedlich also Ausgangspunkte sind
völlig andere und wir sehen ja auch in
den Koalitionen da sind wir eine Ampel
jetzt auch aber auch eine Koalitionen
auf Landesebene schwarze und grüne
kommen ja oft gar nicht voran aber
natürlich vertagen problemlos wissen Sie
noch viel besser als ich vertagen
Probleme in Kommissionen dann werden die
Termine so gelegt dass man daran einigen
wir uns danach und am Ende bezahlt der
Steuerzahler das ist natürlich auch gut
klar so kann ich immer machen die nicht
sagen ich mache Projekte damit schwarze
und grün sich wohlfühlen und lasse die
Kosten dem Steuerzahler auf
jeder Hinsicht Tradition keinem von mir
sein die Meinungsforscher sind da ganz
klar wie die wie die Überschneidung
nochmal die Koalition von Boris rein in
Hessen von Hendrik wüst im
Nordrhein-Westfalen von Daniel Günther
in Schleswig-Holstein funktionieren viel
besser als die große Koalition im Bund
sagen wie das war als als Hessen die
Hessen die die hessische CDU hat das
schlechteste Wahlergebnis aller Zeiten
eingefahren seitdem sie wegen grün
regiert das muss ihnen doch zu denken
wir gehen jetzt wieder zurück auf die
Bundesliga wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung es kann
nicht wahr sein jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie